hello and welcome to ee 104
or cme 107. this is the course
uh introduction to machine learning at
stanford university
spring 2020. my name is sanjay lau i am
the
instructor of this class this class
was written by myself and professor
stephen boyd at stanford
over the past three years now we are
as you know in the middle of uh
corona virus outbreak and
um as a result much of the university is
closed
and many of you are working at home
um the course is therefore going to be
entirely
online all of the lectures will be
pre-recorded and we will not have any
live
lectures unfortunately we are aware that
many of you are
watching these these lectures from
a variety of different time zones and we
will do our best to
accommodate that we will post new
lectures
every tuesday and thursday morning and
we will hold office hours via zoom
due to the current situation there will
be no exams in this class
all classes in the school of engineering
are going to be credit and
or no credit only and this class is no
exception
um but there will be homework uh it will
be uh given out weekly
now the homework will be about half
programming
and the other half will be conceptual
questions maybe a little bit of
mathematics
the programming questions we'll be using
julia for those
julio is a modern language which is
developed primarily for
numerical computing and machine learning
in particular it's very
fast it's got a very nice syntax which
makes it
very simple to write sophisticated
programs
you do not need to have a very
sophisticated understanding
of the julia programming language most
of the coding that we will do in this
class is very short
scripts we will be using the flux
machine learning package that is a
package that sits on top of julia
there are some prerequisites in this
class in particular linear algebra
we will be using a lot of the notation
of linear algebra and we will
need you to be familiar with things such
as least squares
and a basic understanding of eigenvalues
and eigenvectors later in the class
we don't need anything more
sophisticated than that so any first
class in the new algebra will cover
enough
similarly for programming we do need you
to be able to write code
but very simple code will suffice well
as i said we're going to
only going to be writing short scripts
but you do need to be familiar with how
to bring data in how to generate plots
how to understand what data types are
you don't need to have any understanding
of complex data structures
or object-oriented programming or
anything like that
probability is a co-requisite not a
prerequisite
so any basic class and probability will
do
you can if you haven't taken it up until
now you can take it concurrently with
the class and that's fine
we won't be using probability for the
first few weeks
but after that we'll start to use the
the both the language
and some of the ideas and methods of
probability as well
and that brings me to the end of the
mechanics section
of the class
i hope you enjoy the e104
you